- [Kelly] So Elizabeth
dropped out of school.
- Yes she did.
- And I wanted
to ask about this photo that you posted
'cause this feels like
you're back in school.
Is this your school?
- I went back!
I went back to Allentown.
I made it a point, I
kept having these dreams,
you know, since I graduated which was,
I don't know, many years ago.
- Yeah, just like a couple, yeah. (laughs)
- Was it?
And, I was like, you know what?
I think I'm just gonna go
back and see the school
and see if they'll let me go
and it took me a while to
get somebody to call me back.
I was like, I think this is
going to change something in me.
I think the anxiety that I get,
the anxiety dreams that I get,
I will no longer have if
I go and see it in person
and see what's changed and
support it and whatever,
and I did and they were awesome.
I went to... My husband's a theater guy,
and I was never in the
theater department in school.
I did not act in school
'cause I was intimidated.
- That's ironic!
- I know, it's weird.
- Okay.
- It was weird, I was
only singing, though.
I went and I saw this guy, Mr. Sackler,
whose like this local
famous theater director.
And he was talking to me,
he was like showing us the black box
and showing us all these cool things.
It was like, this is the
show we're doing next
and my husband's like, wow,
what a cool school you went to!
And I was like, I was never
a part of any of this.
(Kelly laughs)
And he had no idea, and he mentioned me
and I had my mask on.
- Wait, the teacher?
- The teacher mentioned me.
He's like, and Amanda Sey-
And I pulled my mask down
and I was like, I should probably,
I feel like I'm lying to you.
And I took my mask down
and he screamed and ran across the room.
And it was like the most
amazing thing I'd ever seen,
most amazing like, reaction.
And I realized-
- Aw, I love that he didn't know.
- Yeah, and it was amazing for him.
And I was like I'll come back
and talk to your theater
students 'cause like--
- Even if you have a
mask on, you have like,
the most recognizable
eyes in all of the lands.
Like, what?
(audience laughs)
- I think he's just
super busy in his head.
- Okay, I was like--
- I mean, he's amazing.
- [Kelly] He is not observant.
- No!
- I was like, wait.
- And I think he knows
that and it was so cute.
He was like, ahhh!
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was like, oh my God, thank you.
- [Kelly] Aw, I love that.
- And so he lives with us now.
(Kelly laughs)
Because it was very flattering.
- He lives with us now.
- No, but it was cool.
Go back to high school if you can.
If you were traumatized in
high school, try to go back.
It might help.
- I wasn't, what was traumatizing?
I wasn't traumatized, I
just didn't wanna be there.
(audience laughs)
- I didn't wanna be there.
- That was it!
- It was girl stuff.
- Oh, girls are mean.
- See that's why, I had a few like,
good, solid, like girlfriends.
- I did too, I'm still best
friends with my girlfriend.
We have a company together.
We literally talk every day.
- No people are mean, girls are mean.
I will say that, girls are really mean.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And now if I run into them in town,
we'll be like, oh hey, how are you doing?
But like in high school it was like--
- I know, but here's the best part.
Girl, you don't even
need to run into them.
They can just watch you.
Hey!
(audience applauding)